nothing gave me as much joy with the
exception of once a nick always a nick
bobby portis being an nba champion but
nothing gave me as much joy
as seeing marcus johnson going down the
street in milwaukee with his shirt off
doing the j.r smith you know incredible
woman
and he's kind enough to join the show
right now we don't know if the shirt is
still
off but we appreciate you making some
time that was incredible man what was
going through your mind when you were
going down the streets of milwaukee with
no shirt on
well you know it was just kind of a spur
of the moment
just going with the flow kind of a thing
but what really happened
was that uh brandon jennings
the author of an originator of buxom six
he was uh like a car ahead of me and so
he was
he was slamming beers he must have
slammed about 20 beers i swear to god
they were just that he was taking his
shirt off and throwing him to the crowd
they'd bring him another shirt he put it
on
he slammed a few more beer so he kind of
got me in the spirit you know
well with the way with the exception of
the slamming beer's pride i don't drink
anymore
i could probably out back in the day but
anyway
so so i started taking my shirt off and
you know it just got good to me and
and i would plan some like the signing
bottled water
but all i can handle at my age and uh
but but you know it was it was just a
fun time and that we had a ball i mean i
don't know how many
hundreds of thousands of people they
estimated was out there but but it was
just
nuts and it was it was so much fun and
my family my wife in particular had
had probably more fun than the guys and
the people who were on the sidelines uh
cheering us on and ladies and kids and
all that so
we had a ball man we had a ball it was
great pj tucker talked about uh the team
was full of dogs they just didn't know
that they were dogs
are you a dog do you know that you're a
dog do you need pj tucker to help you
become a dog bow wow wow yippy yo yip
no i you know i don't need pj's help is
you know i'm a dog in my own arena now
just the broadcasting acting writing
kind of arena
uh and just the tenacity to go out there
and get it and be
tough and get knocked down and back back
and get up and keep coming you know
and that's what pj means and so pj
for me was one of the key acquisitions
and i told john horst that yesterday on
stage
uh as we went to uh uh the deer district
uh right after the parade and the the
the throng of fans but i told john horse
look man
you know that was a cute bringing in pj
of course jule holiday
great acquisition but but in terms of
this team's
edge pj gables people walked on stage
with two
magnum bottles of champagne and he's you
know he's he's
wiggling he's spitting he's he he
he was more i'm gonna post up on twitter
after we get off the air man old school
888
he was more animated talking to jeff p
than he was playing
i mean he was just out of his mind but
but what a great
great guy talk to his mom uh at the
championship
celebration in the locker room and i
just got a lot of respect for him
because
you know he understands his role better
than anybody maybe in nba history
he didn't get out of his role he does
what he does and he relishes
doing what he does to perfection marcus
johnson joins the show
he might still have his shirt off after
the milwaukee bucks parade ben line's
phone in for rich on the rich eisen show
uh such a crazy scene out there it's an
incredible story
the milwaukee bucks winning an nba
championship you
have a special place of course in your
heart for milwaukee having been an
all-star there for many years
so what's it been like for you to
connect with the older fans the ones who
have been through
the the rebuilds and and the terrible
seasons and the losing and the getting
close
and the conference finals and all the
the moments throughout the history of
milwaukee bucks basketball
what's it been like for you to connect
with some of those die-hard older fans
who are getting to experience this
well and i just give you kind of a an
example of what epitomizes that so my
broadcast partner jim paske
35 years as a milwaukee buck announcer i
got there
uh after the championship years
obviously and then
i'll tell you what through some lean
years in milwaukee um
he contracted cobia 19
a couple of weeks ago still dealing with
the centers and he couldn't participate
in any of this
but how how how cool is fate for having
that happen to him
but giannis wears a t-shirt with a heart
on one side and jim paschke's
image on the other every fan let's just
answer your question but all the fans
uh who were from my er the older fans
were like do it for jim do it for jim
but but but it's such a strong
connection because as you mentioned
this franchise has seen some good teams
i mean michael red
uh ben baker got to the conference
semifinals michael red those guys i
think they got to the
they've got to the finals or buckets
short they get the sixers one year
whatever it was
so it's been a lot of close calls along
with my era with the with the larry bird
and the dr
j sixers and celtics we could never get
the past
and so it was just a it was a vicarious
kind of a thrill to be able to
experience this
with this with these guys and when i was
on stage with the guys this is kind of
how i really felt
i mean i just took i took a seat in the
back darving ham and
and then chris miller could come
together two people were like come on up
you know come on up on still within the
plot with us and
and i just know and i just want to sit
back let you guys enjoy the moment but
just allow me to be a part of it and
that's kind of how
you know that that's the epitome of kind
of how the older fans feel this is your
time young fellows
but man we sure are enjoying the moment
and thank you for that
marcus johnson joins the show milwaukee
bucks analyst
i like to introduce him as the father of
josiah johnson the king of nba twitter
you can follow josiah of course at king
josiah54
what was it like to experience the nba
finals with your son i know you guys had
a chance to go out to a couple games
together
had a great time decide came out uh with
good buddy and creative partner and
michael scarberry uh the
the they they joined us in milwaukee
modus and chris was there that was for
game
uh three then chris stayed over for game
four and then i went out to vegas to see
my daughter win the aaa national
championship for 11 and under
that we came back my daughter and my my
my youngest son
and uh my second youngest son mariah he
was on the barwin hills tv show whatever
back
a few years back but we all so we all
were there for game
six the clincher uh in milwaukee and so
we were back in the locker room and the
champagne celebrate
i mean man it was i mean you know to
experience that with you with your kids
and again that's all i posted all that
stuff on twitter it's just such a such a
just a monumental kind of a moment and
and
and and i know in my life it is and i
can imagine something that they would
just never
ever forget being able to to experience
all that to be on deal you know be on
the basketball court down court the
bucks made sure
that we had access to everything we do
with their courts out with adam silver
and
and and malika andrews talking to chris
and talking
right there we're experiencing
everything and it was just uh one of
those moments man that i'm so glad
my wife flew out for the parade she was
gonna pass on that and she's like i
don't know what i was thinking she had
so much fun at that parade
so just to experience that with the
family it's what it's all about man just
to be able to share in the moment
and share these kinds of lasting
memories man that that will be indelibly
indebtedly imprinted on on the
consciousness of my kids minds forever
marcus you've been a hollywood guy for a
long time now you've had a lot of
success in film and tv
as a writer producer as well what if i
picture a story about a kid from greece
who used to sell trinkets on the street
who 10 years later came to the united
states and became a basketball god would
you believe it
yeah well you know probably not you know
you had to share a pair of shoes with
his older brother because they couldn't
afford two pairs so they got one pair
they
and then two or three of them shared
those shoes together uh
mom and dad did the tremendous job they
did dad passes away
uh at a young age uh three or four years
ago of a heart attack unexpectedly
and and you know and all this kind of
stuff just happens for this that
two brothers those two brothers that
share those pair of shoes
on the same team this year able to share
this moment together
i mean it is such a wonderful wonderful
american success story and then you tap
it all off with janet's better kubo
being is as humble you know you know
he's got ego don't get me wrong he's not
he's got ego you don't have
that kind of greatness to not have ego
but but he is such a wonderful person
genuine person to be around
and it's a story that's gonna get made
uh you know i i try to i try to talk him
in the midden uh
friend of mine michael starbury josiah's
buddy uh a great writer uh
write write the story but he'd already
gotten somebody on board to handle that
for him but
you know they're in the process now
trying to make make that story and what
a fitting
not the end of it this season but but
it's one of the climaxes of this
his life of his career and uh so just
just beautiful the way this thing is
worked out 50 years since since he won a
championship
he dropped 50 exactly in the closeout
game i mean
you know you couldn't have scripted it
any better marcus we got the birthday
boys in studio here chris brockman and
tj jefferson trying to put down what we
now affectionately called the giannis
which is a 50 piece of nuggets and half
sprite
right half lemonade and they're not even
getting through 10 or 20.
let alone a 50 piece yeah it markets
it's not going down well
i mean i appreciate i apprecia i
appreciate the thought but
the execution is going to be really
really tough
that's a lot of nuggets man now that the
parade's over
there is a flight that is leaving
milwaukee today a direct fight to tokyo
and it's got devin booker drew holiday
and chris middleton on it a very
uncomfortable flight
i would imagine for devon as drew and
chris probably still smell like
champagne
yeah what was it you know go ahead no i
was just gonna ask you like you know
what was it about those two olympians
that you just enjoyed watching
throughout this entire
bucks run well all three of them really
seriously i mean i enjoyed devon too
don't
don't get it twisted i mean devin was i
mean he was just superb
uh but for most of the playoffs kind of
cooled off a bit in that game six
but uh drew and and and chris obviously
it was game
five um in phoenix
yeah that was the game you know and that
was a game but you know drew took over
in that second quarter
chris took over in that third you know
and and they've done it all throughout
the playoffs even though drew
at one point had the lowest effective
field goal percentage of any player
uh with a certain minimum of physical
attempts so he was struggling to knock
down shots
but i i told his pops i was like look
sean do i'm loving what drew's bringing
to the table
you know he's gonna hit his shot at some
point but even if he doesn't what he's
doing defensively and distributing the
basketball
and and his physicality on the court and
then chris middleton he's another great
story he think he's a guy that was
you know you know and heralded coming
out of college second round pick went to
the g league a throw in
in the deal from detroit that uh that
brought him to milwaukee
and here he is a two-time all-star nba
champion so i i'm so
uh just elated for him that had the kind
of success he had see this championship
is going to
going to really help a lot of these guys
in terms of feeling so good about
themselves and where they belong
in the pantheon of nba greatness that
it's going to have
you know residual positive after effects
for years to come
a you know career and post career for
these guys so it's just a monumental
accomplishment that uh that has so many
benefits uh uh
concurrently and down the road milwaukee
bucks analysts and five-time nba
all-star marcus johnson joins the show
ben lyon's filling in for rich on the
rich eisen show
you never know what rumors to believe in
hollywood marcus you never know what's
true you hear whisperings about projects
but
i've been i've been hearing about a
project in the works for a long time
it's a
it's a spin-off of white man can't jump
with raymond it's a bremen sequel
where's raymond right now in his career
yeah man you know that's what uh it's
funny we were
going on the parade route it was so many
raymond is that you
you know there was so many of that that
those kinds of comments going on but
you know but even seriously about that
with blake griffin somebody was trying
to get that
sequel going but hadn't gone anywhere
but now they ought to go ahead and flip
that thing and make it about raymond man
the life of raymond what he's doing now
and
and uh you know i can i can give some
narration to the old school raven to get
a young lamb to kind of do some
flashbacks and we can get a cracker man
we can get this cracking
i see raymond maybe dedicated his life
to a higher power to faith he's gone
down the the straighter path
right now but his demons keep calling
him back he's sober
he's he's spiritual right now but he's
still got that edge you know what i'm
saying he he
but you don't want to mess with raven
still you know he still got that edge he
still carries that blade though
[Laughter]
carry that blade in the name of the lord
but he's still carrying it
[Laughter]
marcus johnson joins the show ben lyons
filling in for rich on the rich eisen
show
hey marcus i just this is tj here i just
had a quick question for you
um michael jordan
widely recognizes the greatest
basketball player of all time
had your picture hanging up in his dorm
room
at north carolina and i'm sure you've
probably talked about it a million times
but never here on the rich eisen show i
just want to know what that felt like
knowing that the guy who
millions of basketball fans around the
earth
adored had you on his wall well look and
i'll tell you a quick story we see the
movie space jam and
and he invited a bunch of the ucla kids
uh my son chris was one of them so i was
hanging out with him every day
on the on the space space jam bubble or
whatever
it was and along with barkley and grant
hill and john howard and dennis rodman
just one of the greatest runs of history
so we're playing a little three on three
dean kane superman is on one team and me
and michael and everybody's playing
after we get through playing or game
point i think i catch it inside
and i do a little dunk so michael's like
hey old man oh man don't be trying to
duck out here don't be trying to dunk
out here
you're too old you never did that when
you played you never do that when you
played i looked at michael i said man
whatever i did when i played
you had my poster on your wall in
college brother so i must have been
doing something right
and he just he just got all just
embarrassed and blushing
you right you right about that i loved
your game but i loved your game together
yeah that gave me a chance to kind of
one-up michael and how how many people
can say that that you can one-up michael
jordan you know into that
that's always been always been a
highlight of my
about somewhere somewhat pedestrian life
you know just being able to one-up
michael jordan so yeah it's all good
that's what's
been an incredible basketball journey
and it's going to be a fun summer i
would imagine for everybody that's part
of the bucks family
marcus we appreciate you putting on a
shirt and joining the show
anytime man it's all good actually i'm
still on still
i'm on cloud 10 thinking about cloud9
i'm still up there with cloud 10 minutes
and i don't want to come down but it's
been beautiful send josiah my best we
appreciate you jumping on the show man
real man thank you ben marcus johnson
marcus five-time nba all-star
shirtless at the parade hell yeah that's
amazing
a what a great story too just dunking on
michael jordan and the space jam bubble
those runs were
were absolutely legendary marcus johnson
good stuff you know he dunks on his
birthday every year still this is uh
at old school 88 for the folks watching
on peacock uh
he dumps he dunks on on his birthday
he's in his 60s now throwing it down
that's this year with the mask on
steel that's fantastic in his all-star
jersey by the way
fantastic got a wonderful cactus in the
backyard there southern california
living
marcus johnson wow hey you watched all
the way to the end thanks for that
watch more right here